Caption: we have um uma and Diana sorry
Caption: talking looking for a pet project here
Caption: is a list of humanity's biggest
Caption: challenges thank you good morning
Caption: everyone good morning so we're starting
Caption: with a blank list but the list of
Caption: humanity's biggest challenges is
Caption: certainly non blank we'll get to it
Caption: we're going to start in a bit unusual
Caption: way today
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first Wow
Caption: have you seen this visualization before
Caption: for those who hasn't seen this one it
Caption: can have a profound effect because what
Caption: we see here is an average lifespan of
Caption: Australian split in two weeks in 83
Caption: years if you like it and look after
Caption: yourself split in two weeks and
Caption: presented and this one screen those Li
Caption: weeks that already in the past marked in
Caption: red and those that already in the future
Caption: are blue everything that you've
Caption: experienced and everything that's left
Caption: to experience is this on one screen and
Caption: how long is really one week it's one
Caption: dinner with your family one call to your
Caption: parents a couple of poor requests is
Caption: gone and you don't have to zoom in to
Caption: see that week that that's the scariest
Caption: bit to add even more drama Chisolm to my
Caption: opening I accounted to all downtime all
Caption: the time that we spent asleep one-third
Caption: of our time and all the time we spend in
Caption: the office working hard providing for
Caption: our families and ourselves when we're
Caption: old and frail so what is left what is
Caption: left is not much it's 11 rows of weeks
Caption: and it's up to you what you want to do
Caption: with those 11 rows of weeks you can
Caption: choose to make more money or you can
Caption: choose to consume more things or change
Caption: more entertainment or you can have a
Caption: stop at one of the humanity's biggest
Caption: challenges but what are they who
Caption: maintains the ultimate list of
Caption: humanity's biggest challenges day
Caption: well the Millennium Project is a
Caption: think-tank
Caption: in behalf of humanity their organization
Caption: is non governmental and non for profit
Caption: and they dedicate their time finding the
Caption: top challenges we face and put them into
Caption: a framework what anyone can work with
Caption: regarding contact with the managing
Caption: director of this organization he was
Caption: thrilled to know that we'll be sharing
Caption: this with the brightest minds in
Caption: well going back to our 11 weeks why
Caption: would you bother to spend your precious
Caption: time on one of these problems that not
Caption: even hard to define yet along hard to
Caption: try to solve because of this photo this
Caption: is our earth as Carl Sagan put it we all
Caption: live on a pale blue dot that whizzes
Caption: through empty space at 930 km/h and well
Caption: here this is us this is the only home
Caption: we've ever known and we'll have one-way
Caption: ticket
Caption: sorry to announce it and I also believe
Caption: we have a responsibility for our
Caption: children and we have younger generation
Caption: of the edvac hi Lara we have a
Caption: responsibility for all our children to
Caption: leave this place a little bit nicer than
Caption: we found it but you know what as human
Caption: beings we're not really that good at
Caption: staying motivated with these grand
Caption: motivations right we need something a
Caption: bit more selfish something closer to
Caption: heart something that we can think about
Caption: every day so what isn't it for me tea
Caption: well we're not here to convince anyone
Caption: we believe everyone is kind we have a
Caption: good heart we want to do something but
Caption: what can you do
Caption: you can donate money to a charity you
Caption: can go to the soup kitchen or you can
Caption: put your best weapon toward the keyboard
Caption: do you remember those nights at uni or
Caption: at work when you just sew into something
Caption: time to supplies you're learning new
Caption: skills you're doing this amazing thing
Caption: with things that matter
Caption: so let's say you want to get into
Caption: machine learning you can do a tutorial
Caption: that will ask you to differentiate
Caption: puppies versus kittens or pick up the
Caption: fake copter versus the real hot dog
Caption: it's not really gonna stop you from
Caption: going through the movies on a Saturday
Caption: afternoon we also believe there is gonna
Caption: make it more interesting person imagine
Caption: the situation I just watch some Netflix
Caption: a junk-food had a great time t what
Caption: about you
Caption: what did you do well I watch some
Caption: Netflix as well documentary as human
Caption: trafficking do you know they captured
Caption: them with all my dads today I was
Caption: thinking it sounds like a classification
Caption: problem so I use semi-supervised
Caption: learning to properly classify those
Caption: fake-out so people will not get trapped
Caption: into them wow this is next-level team
Caption: this is level up but how do you even
Caption: start thinking like that how would you
Caption: get inspired how would you spend your
Caption: Saturday afternoon working on this stuff
Caption: what was your inspiration my inspiration
Caption: is hands rustling have you heard of him
Caption: the founder of Gapminder foundation yep
Caption: he is a pioneer in to making data
Caption: interesting to make an insightful and to
Caption: make it reaches in a way that it hasn't
Caption: done in a long time so his videos his
Caption: tutorials are amazing so let's all have
Caption: have a look a common misunderstanding is
Caption: that if we save all the poor children
Caption: the world will become overpopulated
Caption: this may sound logical but it's wrong
Caption: it's the other way around saving the
Caption: poor children's lives is required to end
Caption: population growth now look at the UN
Caption: numbers poor parents on average have
Caption: five children and one dies look two
Caption: parents are replaced by four surviving
Caption: children in the next generation
Caption: this means population is growing very
Caption: fast among the poorest this is the
Caption: average family in the worst of places
Caption: like Congo and Afghanistan today where
Caption: child mortality is highest
Caption: that's where population is growing
Caption: faster than anywhere else how many
Caption: people live like this there are seven
Caption: billion people in the world one block 1
Caption: billion the poorest 2 billion they live
Caption: like this the other 5 billion they have
Caption: this average family two parents having
Caption: two children and there are few child
Caption: deaths this is the majority of the world
Caption: population not only Europe and the US is
Caption: throughout religions and cultures China
Caption: in rural Mexico large cities in Africa
Caption: today in most population children just
Caption: replace parents and the size of
Caption: generations are no longer increasing
Caption: this means the population will stop
Caption: growing how did so many people end up
Caption: with smaller families when their
Caption: children stopped dying as they left
Caption: extreme poverty and girls got education
Caption: parents no longer had to compensate for
Caption: child death by having many babies and a
Caption: large family stopped being an economic
Caption: necessity or a social status symbol and
Caption: with modern contraceptives parents
Caption: across the world the majority decided to
Caption: have a small family so by saving the
Caption: lives of poor children and helping the
Caption: last two billion out of poverty these
Caption: parents will also decide to have fewer
Caption: children and fewer eventually reaching
Caption: the two child family that showed that
Caption: you and family size forecast up to the
Caption: end of the century then the world
Caption: population is expected to stop growing
Caption: before it stops another four billion
Caption: people will be added to the world
Caption: population four billion more that's a
Caption: lot of
Caption: people but the longer poor children
Caption: keeps dying and this change is delayed
Caption: the more billions will be added so
Caption: ending population growth starts by
Caption: saving the poorest children this this is
Caption: very inspirational have you ever felt so
Caption: excited about the modern contraception
Caption: this guy has a talent for sure well but
Caption: where do you start with how do you take
Caption: all this passion and find your belly and
Caption: put it into something tangible
Caption: you need a framework you need to start
Caption: with a couple of steps where two data
Caption: scientists so we see every problem as a
Caption: data problem so we're gonna propose the
Caption: data science framework so this is what
Caption: it looks like you start with an idea
Caption: something that sounds doesn't sound
Caption: right something you care about and you
Caption: gotta care about a lot because you have
Caption: to put a lot of hours next we need to
Caption: express it as a hypothesis this is one
Caption: of the hardest steps take an idea take a
Caption: feeling and express it in a testable
Caption: hypothesis next depending on sort of
Caption: data that you possess and types of
Caption: questions you want to answer you have
Caption: three data avenues or we propose 3.11
Caption: use number one visualization so you can
Caption: explore it that I understand it and
Caption: change someone's mind or provide
Caption: insights for this one you need I could
Caption: get it data you can get it from the
Caption: World Bank or UN or Hospital Records
Caption: just like hands raw Singh and his
Caption: foundation do next Avenue is simulations
Caption: the current computer power allows us to
Caption: simulate multiple predictions or
Caption: multiple scenarios as they pan out so if
Caption: you into this sort of stuff you need
Caption: data based assumptions then we have
Caption: predictive modeling you can forecast
Caption: things like for example the spread of a
Caption: disease
Caption: for this one you need very particular
Caption: data you need granular data and
Caption: hopefully labeled okay once you have
Caption: that once you chose your path there's a
Caption: lot of hard work and experimentation
Caption: going in you along the way you learn new
Caption: skills pick up new tools and what's the
Caption: reward the reward is that you share
Caption: community and you have an opinion that
Caption: is based on something rather than just
Caption: an anecdotal evidence or a media report
Caption: take it away d okay so let's start with
Caption: visualizations we have a question if
Caption: 2018 do we produce and consume our food
Caption: efficiently is food waste a worldwide
Caption: problem surely has decreased we know
Caption: more about it it's everywhere well we
Caption: took data from the Food and Agriculture
Caption: Organization of the UN use toggle public
Caption: which is a free tool and then plotted
Caption: some of their numbers what we can see
Caption: here is that population has been
Caption: increasing slowly we're almost 8 billion
Caption: already and waste has been discrete
Caption: increasing as well as steadily numbers
Caption: so what about if we look at average
Caption: waste per capita it has been increasing
Caption: as well quite steadily and up there what
Caption: we can do is look at countries and their
Caption: average waste per person this allows us
Caption: to compare countries with totally
Caption: different populations so let's say you
Caption: want to compare China Haiti is it
Caption: Kazakhstan here yeah where is Bharat
Caption: looking ok what about in Australia so
Caption: okay okay so in Australia were in a very
Caption: specific situation eighty to ninety
Caption: percent of the food that we consume is
Caption: produced nationally but a big chunk is
Caption: not getting to the supermarkets twenty
Caption: percent gets wasted before it reaches
Caption: the shelves why because we have consumer
Caption: standards we have beauty standards for
Caption: our fruits and veggies we don't like
Caption: them to be ugly or to brown or too
Caption: skinny this is the distribution of upon
Caption: royal gala from a supermarket is the
Caption: pink one and the blue one is what you
Caption: would expect from nature so it's totally
Caption: truncated the one from that supermarket
Caption: if we only accepting those kind of
Caption: eyeballs we don't want the rest of them
Caption: what about home we do the grocery
Caption: shopping then we take the food and we
Caption: cook we we are wasting one third of our
Caption: food at home the Australian government
Caption: spent a lot of money in a research they
Caption: asked people to go through the Europeans
Caption: and categorize the waste and what they
Caption: found was that almost 40% of the food
Caption: that's being wasted is fresh food a big
Caption: chunk is well 25 percent leftovers what
Caption: it is telling us we're buying too much
Caption: we're cooking too much we're not eating
Caption: a lot
Caption: so our takeaways if you're buying more
Caption: than 10 kilos per person per week you're
Caption: buying too much
Caption: sorry okay you go thank you very much
Caption: dear and now I know I can't really lift
Caption: 10 kgs over my head oh no I can but I
Caption: cannot lift my groceries above my head
Caption: simulations this is a topic that I find
Caption: absolutely fascinating so there
Caption: Montecarlo situation simulations or
Caption: there are other simulations I
Caption: particularly like agent-based modeling
Caption: what is it it is a type of modeling that
Caption: allows you to observe the behavior of
Caption: the whole system by setting very simple
Caption: rules of individual agents in this
Caption: simulation the poster child of
Caption: simulation agent-based modeling is
Caption: Schelling's segregation model let's have
Caption: a look at it so this is our agent our
Caption: citizen blue he lives on this checkered
Caption: board he has the sameness threshold he
Caption: is going to be happy only if at least
Caption: three neighbors around him ah as blue as
Caption: he is
Caption: and these blueness can be anything it
Caption: could be income level it could be race
Caption: so there you go that's his eight
Caption: neighbors and only two of them are the
Caption: same as him his threshold tells him to
Caption: move out when you replicate this simple
Caption: behavior over the majority of agents
Caption: that populate the same chessboard you
Caption: see very interesting patterns starting
Caption: to emerge let's have a look so what I
Caption: did here I set up a pretty tolerable
Caption: threshold for I only want half of my
Caption: neighbors to be like me then I kick off
Caption: the popular the simulation and what we
Caption: see that slowly but surely a pattern
Caption: becomes to emerge all the Reds go to one
Caption: corner and all the Blues go to another
Caption: corner and below here we see a number of
Caption: happy agents so once I'm happy I settle
Caption: down and not only its segregated look at
Caption: the gaps so this shows us how mild
Caption: individual preferences can result in a
Caption: vast listing
Caption: societies well simulations are great but
Caption: are they really true like there's so
Caption: many reasons why someone might choose to
Caption: move out or move in in a particular
Caption: neighborhood but the funny thing about
Caption: this one is that we actually see this in
Caption: reality so for example this is Melbourne
Caption: and different levels of color here are
Caption: the income levels so throughout the
Caption: years they reach a neighborhood and
Caption: they're not so rich neighborhood and we
Caption: can see the segregation very clearly
Caption: this is census map of Chicago blue dots
Caption: households that identify as black and
Caption: red is the household that identify as
Caption: white and there are other races
Caption: presented as well but this is the most
Caption: interesting one census map of Detroit
Caption: 2010 do you see that clear separation
Caption: line over there
Caption: Eminem fans in the room do you know what
Caption: it is it is the famous 8 Mile Road ok so
Caption: I thought how can I put this to work
Caption: there is one thing that really really
Caption: doesn't sound right to me and this is
Caption: sensitive topic everyone has their own
Caption: opinion but this is what doesn't sound
Caption: right to me why there are people who not
Caption: welcome refugees out of fear that they
Caption: will somehow instill their culture and
Caption: turn our country into their country
Caption: that's all right here sometimes ok this
Caption: is a grand idea but how do you express
Caption: it as a hypothesis so with agent-based
Caption: modeling what fraction of agents of
Caption: guest culture can a host nation absorb
Caption: without turning into the guest culture
Caption: and I need some assumptions to make this
Caption: simulation work so here's our hosts and
Caption: guests and first assumption is
Caption: assimilation rate so we know that the
Caption: more integrated is refugee the more
Caption: assimilated they become the faster they
Caption: learned language the faster they will
Caption: embrace local culture
Caption: so overtime you've given enough
Caption: neighbors of host culture around them
Caption: they turn into one of the host culture
Caption: agency another assumption is replica
Caption: recreation rate so agents see enough see
Caption: a suitable candidate around them and
Caption: they get married and they have children
Caption: you see my games didn't change for the
Caption: last thirty years so this can be a lot
Caption: of fun next while I was working on this
Caption: I dispelled my own myths so I find I
Caption: think this is success already I was
Caption: trying so hard to find some data that
Caption: shows different procreation rates for
Caption: different cultures of course they just
Caption: check just age and some abstracts but
Caption: what was on my mind is Syrian refugee
Caption: crisis and the Western world so yeah
Caption: well we all know it's kind of common
Caption: sense they have bigger families I
Caption: couldn't find anything there is no such
Caption: data as Hans Rosling already told us in
Caption: the beginning it has nothing to do with
Caption: religion or culture it has everything to
Caption: do with income level so the moment
Caption: family grows out of extreme poverty they
Caption: decide to have less children so these
Caption: are my assumptions how do i model this i
Caption: model is based on already existing
Caption: algorithm such as shelling segregation
Caption: model and wolf ship predation and I use
Caption: Meza price and framework because I want
Caption: to learn a bit about Python and get
Caption: better this programming language so I
Caption: want to show you one scenario and how it
Caption: pans out I set it to 243 which is
Caption: roughly about Australian population site
Caption: 24 million and then I said number of
Caption: guests to 73 say seven million seven
Caption: minutes huge number then I simulate this
Caption: and you see agents moving around getting
Caption: married having children and then with
Caption: this particular scenario I can see that
Caption: the population is in balance well I'm
Caption: not going to defend a PhD thesis with
Caption: this just yet so what is the action
Caption: point what's the point of all this room
Caption: one well the point for me is to be an
Caption: advocate
Caption: it next time I have a kitchen
Caption: conversation with someone of a
Caption: completely different view I will have
Caption: not find my belly I will have an opinion
Caption: that I can defend and will change the
Caption: world one kitchen conversation one
Caption: person at the time thank you
Caption: so let's move to machine learning
Caption: machine learning is changing the world
Caption: but what is it is the ability for
Caption: computers to learn without being
Caption: explicitly programmed interesting so
Caption: this is an idea firm that's taxpayers
Caption: money around the world go to welfare
Caption: programs right but how do we know that
Caption: those who need it the most are getting
Caption: it how do you know if a household is
Caption: poor you'll say well you just asked them
Caption: to complete a form look at the tax
Caption: returns well this is not a possibility
Caption: in a lot of developing countries they
Caption: don't have the infrastructure there are
Caption: problems like corruption
Caption: for example the Costa Rican government
Caption: wants to take all the power of machine
Caption: learning to be able to correctly
Caption: classify houses for are they extremely
Caption: poor do they need a system or they do
Caption: not need assistance they have also
Caption: engaged the community they have asked
Caption: people like you that want to use data
Caption: science for good to help them be to
Caption: build the model so why are they asking
Caption: for we have a hundred and forty two
Caption: features of a house so someone has gone
Caption: there to the house look at everything
Caption: and then they have labeled them as
Caption: extremely poor North the features are
Caption: like for example piso de madera do they
Caption: have wooden floors or heavy or HEPA is
Caption: the main provider male or female
Caption: computer or no computer a computer once
Caption: we have all of those features then the
Caption: next time they get an application for
Caption: assistance someone doesn't have to go
Caption: there and look at the house the computer
Caption: will tell you the model will say yes
Caption: they do need assistance or no they told
Caption: so that that sounds really interesting
Caption: this is something I want to get into
Caption: but we also cheated here we did not know
Caption: I didn't want to go through data
Caption: collection and data cleaning problem so
Caption: we joined a competition on cargo this is
Caption: a platform because you know what we
Caption: saved ourselves about 80 percent of time
Caption: like that there is not so sexy side of
Caption: data science about 80 percent of time we
Caption: spend cleaning gating data creating
Caption: features polishing than looking for
Caption: leakages and only then in a 20% of time
Caption: that remains we can apply ml machine
Caption: learning magic and machine learning is
Caption: no magic one of the biggest aha moments
Caption: for me when I just started I'm still a
Caption: beginner but one of the biggest aha
Caption: moments was is that machine learning is
Caption: no magic if the one of the one of the
Caption: best indicators of the quality of your
Caption: machine learning prediction is human
Caption: expert given enough time and a quiet
Caption: room and enough data if they start to
Caption: see the signal in the data if they with
Caption: the domain knowledge start to understand
Caption: what's about to happen then there's a
Caption: hope that machine learning algorithm can
Caption: also pick up the signal in this noise
Caption: what was your ha moment II know answer
Caption: moment is rubbish in rubbish out if you
Caption: have no idea where you get into the
Caption: model you have no idea what you're
Caption: getting so get close to your data get
Caption: personal no it doesn't have missing
Caption: values why does he have correlations do
Caption: we need to transform the data then you
Caption: will be able to do a really good model
Caption: you can plot it it will tell you how the
Caption: distributions look they have
Caption: correlations do you need some feature
Caption: engineering for example we can see there
Caption: is a strong correlation between
Caption: overcrowding and the house size not a
Caption: surprise but it could give you some
Caption: clues or way to start and now that I
Caption: know my data
Caption: there were best buddies then you can
Caption: apply the model
Caption: alright and there are many ways on
Caption: algorithm to go search for this signal
Caption: in your data there mind maps like this
Caption: one from scikit-learn that exist where
Caption: you can just
Caption: based on the type of question you trying
Caption: to answer based on the value you trying
Caption: to predict and based on the number of
Caption: observation you possess you can choose
Caption: an algorithm to start at least a
Caption: starting point and here is one catch
Caption: I'm ready to save the world I made
Caption: myself some tea I sit down I can't even
Caption: install the library like this is a
Caption: massive turnoff how we need a lowest
Caption: point of entry as low as we can so for
Caption: this I thought out of my personal
Caption: experience there's one tool that I
Caption: particularly like it's so visual it's
Caption: gonna with your interest it will it's a
Caption: cheese it will show you what's possible
Caption: and then you can get get back to the
Caption: real tools Python dinar and make the job
Caption: done but let's have a look at this
Caption: cheese a tool it's called big amount big
Caption: machine learning they're they're free
Caption: versions available but let's just have a
Caption: quick look we have about 10 minutes left
Caption: our talk so this is me I upload our
Caption: Costa Rica train and the test set so the
Caption: ID in data science you take your data
Caption: then you split it usually 820 don't you
Caption: train you algorithm on the 80 and you
Caption: use the rest to check the results well
Caption: this is all done in one click here next
Caption: I can go and I click on a model that I
Caption: want to build again so for example for
Caption: this one average build random forests
Caption: random forest decision tree neural net
Caption: and some proprietary algorithm that they
Caption: possess so how about we have a look at
Caption: one of the models
Caption: because it's a classification problem
Caption: and what this algorithm is trying to do
Caption: is to make a decision based on multiple
Caption: features what target should we assign to
Caption: this household we can see it straight
Caption: away that some features are more
Caption: important than others hogar Nino
Caption: that's number of children but as we know
Caption: the relationship between relationship
Caption: with reason and the outcome is not it's
Caption: not like that it's not because they have
Caption: more children household is poor it's
Caption: quite the other way around and once we
Caption: have this decision tree we can evaluate
Caption: the model this is the part when I took
Caption: the rest of the data the 20% unseen and
Caption: I come up our algorithm comes up with a
Caption: with the labels and then we just simply
Caption: compare them to what we already see in
Caption: the data
Caption: so in this like I just like how it shows
Caption: you in a very visual way the confusion
Caption: matrix the false positives that the true
Caption: positives the false negatives this
Caption: becomes much easier to understand and it
Caption: gives you idea what you should be even
Caption: looking for so for example for this
Caption: particular problem we probably don't
Caption: want to miss those household that really
Caption: really need help so those with label one
Caption: right so it's okay if we miss label some
Caption: of the other households and as those
Caption: that need assistance but we don't want
Caption: to miss those so this means that we need
Caption: a high recall algorithm and lower
Caption: precision next once the algorithm is
Caption: prepared we can go ahead and even come
Caption: up and even test it so say I'm a Costa
Caption: Rica government official and what I want
Caption: to do this is my
Caption: yeah and then I can set an unseen a new
Caption: application comes in I set up the
Caption: outcome how many children do they have
Caption: do they have my valve on what's the
Caption: education level and obviously I
Caption: understand the Spanish so I would be
Caption: much more fish than this and it will
Caption: give me with with a probability of 56%
Caption: and outcome this is a house of the label
Caption: too so that's not support moderate
Caption: poverty so once you have an idea of how
Caption: this works and what to look for you can
Caption: go back to the Orthodox all tools like
Caption: Python LR and create your own machine
Caption: learning algorithm and this is what we
Caption: do with it yes so we have made a
Caption: submission in Catalan we're competing on
Caption: this lowly climbing the ladder and the
Caption: cattle for those of you who don't know
Caption: it's a data science competition it's a
Caption: worldwide competition where governments
Caption: and other organizations set out a
Caption: problem for community to solve we
Caption: encourage you if you want to get into a
Caption: machine learning or the other science
Caption: join one of them
Caption: Cargill driven data there's two
Caption: platforms that have a lot of
Caption: competitions for social good well so
Caption: what we tried there are 15 global
Caption: challenges so with visualization we try
Caption: to have a stab at this one how can
Caption: population growth and resources be
Caption: brought into balance with simulations we
Caption: try to have a go at this one how can
Caption: shared values reduce ethnic conflicts
Caption: and terrorism and finally with the
Caption: predictive modeling we try to answer
Caption: this question how can a thecal market
Caption: economies be encouraged to help reduce
Caption: the gap between rich and poor and now
Caption: it's back to you ladies and gentlemen
Caption: what really inspires you what what keeps
Caption: you awake at night which one of those
Caption: problems you will find interesting
Caption: enough and inspiring enough to spend
Caption: your weekends on
Caption: we have made a github page so you can go
Caption: and see there's links to the tutorials
Caption: to competitions to examples an
Caption: explanation of the challenges if you're
Caption: interested there's a lot of resources
Caption: you can go and look for and another
Caption: teaser for you because we did got in
Caption: touch with the founders of millennium
Caption: foundation and also UN they are thinking
Caption: of organizing a hackathon in Perth next
Caption: year and will help to make it happen so
Caption: hopefully if you feel inspired or this
Caption: is some some thought that's gonna be
Caption: buzzing on the back of your mind
Caption: from now until 2019 hopefully we'll see
Caption: you there
Caption: thank you very much thank you
Caption: [Applause]